so I decided to watch us again see what
I could pick up that I didn't catch in
my first video 63 things you missed in
us if you haven't seen that video you
want to watch that first just click or
tap here I also received a ton of great
comments on that video so if you want to
see some things that I missed that
viewers like you picked up on then stick
around to the end of this video so in
the previous video I talked about the
tapes next to the TV at the beginning of
the movie that may have served as
influences for Jordan Peele when making
us such as The Goonies chud and the
right stuff this time I noticed a couple
more the Nightmare on Elm Street perhaps
for Freddy's burned face and iconic
glove and a tape with a custom label
reading either Tuesday nights or
Thursday nights the text was pretty
small I'm not sure exactly what we're
supposed to get from that there was
another movie I still wasn't able to
make out on the shelf the man with two
brains about a man who has a tethered
bond with a female brain Thank You Kelly
for sharing that walk there are a couple
things at the carnival game where a DS
dad wins the thriller t-shirt she says
she wants him to go for prize number 11
which fits in with the repeated
references to number 11 a number that
stands for duality in mirror ism one of
the other available prizes is a Black
Flag shirt I forgot to mention this in
the previous video when I talked about
all the similarities to a DS abduction
in 1986 and the coming of the
doppelgangers in the present but there
are two other Black Flag shirts before
each of those events the carny at the
whack-a-mole game wears one and one of
Josh's twin daughters wears one at the
beach but Rob in the comments took it a
step further the four bars of the Black
Flag logo mirror the 11:11 theme oh my
gosh she's right that's genius look at
this look at it but that's not even the
end of it because camellia reminds us
that Black Flag has a song called the
rise above just like the tethered rise
above to kill their doppelgangers it's
like this band was put here all those
years ago just to be in this movie it's
it's too perfect another thing I noticed
that occurs in both events in 1986 and
the present is that we see people eating
fast food from popper pots Cove with the
parrot mascots in 1986 it's a couple at
the boardwalk and in the present the
family eats it at the beach house
daddy's double is eating a strawberry in
that scene and the son Jason doesn't
feel like eating so it's two people
eating from the restaurants in both
scenarios I discussed the real addy
whistling the itsy bitsy spider went and
the other doppelgangers in red to show
up to the house and I've also noticed
that addy whistles the same tune when
she first goes into the mirror mate
and when we first see the underground
it's a long pullout shot of the rabbits
in cages it's when we return later
they're all running all over the hall
and the cages are empty signifying that
those below have been set loose when
we're first introduced to the family we
see a sticker on the back window of the
car with four stick figures that
represent them they're all holding hands
in a similar fashion to the Hands Across
America protest there's also a picture
in Jason's room near the Merlin picture
that I mentioned in the other video that
depicts children holding hands in the
same pose also he has this lamp that
looks like a jack-in-the-box which is a
toy where something springs up from
below a representation of the
doppelgangers coming up from below at
the beach Josh's wife Kitty brings up
the fact that she got plastic surgery
but Adelaide's doppelganger tells her
you look the same as you did last year
another example of duality kiddies
double after taking over the vacation
house sits in front of a mirror and cuts
the same spot on her face with the
scissors I'm guessing they don't have a
plastic surgeon in the underground
Channel so she's making do with what she
has just before the doppelganger family
shows up at the house fake addy tells
Gabe that she doesn't feel like herself
to what she says I think you look like
yourself a little clue about her not
being the real addy then he makes a joke
about how he thinks he'd be able to beat
up someone with the same physique as her
she doesn't take it well and he
apologizes claiming he was just trying
to lighten the mood right as he says the
word lighten the power goes out which
could be another example of the strange
coincidences that lead up to the
uprising just like the disk landing
directly on the beach towel mush was
kind enough to point out more about that
moments with the disc the frisbee landed
precisely on one of the blue circles on
the beach towel the towel was white and
it had a blue circle around it the
frisbee was red with a star on it us us
that's a great point mush and you know
what else mush it fits in with several
clues about the doubles being something
that only happens in America the opening
text only mentions tunnels that run
under America when asked who they are
Addie replies with we are Americans and
the news broadcast seems to imply that
this is a national crisis making no
mention of other countries also the fake
Addie who once lived on in the tunnels
suggests that they go to Mexico to
escape and she even has a book about
Mexico on the shelf
in their vacation home the scene at the
house with the family versus their
tethers has a few things that I found
interesting for example the family is
almost never on camera together with the
doppelgangers this is probably just to
save some money on visual effects and
make it easier to shoot the movie but
does fit in with the idea that only one
of them can exist on the surface Pluto
with a copy of Jason is the one to start
a fire in the fireplace and he also dies
in a fire at the end
tell him Lee said something that I
really like that the red suit family
sits in front of the fireplace
therefore casting a shadow over the
normal family symbolically switching the
roles I also noticed that the table that
they sit across from each other at is a
mirror so it's like they're seeing
themselves in the mirror there's another
reversal of roles when the daughter's
aura is chased by her tether and the
tether jumps on top of a car and looks
down at her here are a few clues that I
found about Addie being switched with
red when they're trying to devise a plan
she says they think like us they know
where we are how could she know that
without having been one herself
when the two doppelgangers of her kids
die she can be seen looking remorseful
even trying to stop Jason's doppelganger
from backing into the fire some people
were theorizing that this is because
Jason was switched at one point with a
doppelganger like possibly the previous
summer when Jason got locked in the
closet or possibly when he goes to the
bathroom at the beach I don't see how
that would be possible even if the burn
marks did come after the supposed switch
was made I don't see why Jason would
forget about his original family and
explicably start acting like a dog
nothing of that sort happened to Addie
when she was forced to go underground as
a child if that was the case he probably
would have wanted to go back with his
original mother so I have to stick with
my original theory that Jason has the
ability to control Pluto because his mom
is a doppelganger so he's part
doppelganger himself there were two
other clues that you may have missed
about the ADI that we follow as an
adults being the fake and the one
underground being the real Adelaide when
Gabe's wife goes back into the house to
get the deceased Josh's car keys she
goes the last of the remaining to tether
twins when doing so she makes grunting
noises similar to that of the other
doppelgangers also back in the 80s when
we see the flashback of her parents
taking her to the doctor she's playing
with these toy animals some of the same
animals can be seen on the wall of the
mirror maze that she lived under at the
end of the movie in the last shot so the
number 11:11 can be seen on top of the
ambulance that they ride away in now
let's look at the rest of the comments
left on my previous video another Easter
Egg nobody's talking about the Sun
eating dry fruit loops while they're
sitting at the round table at their
friend's house
after killing the doppelgangers little
omage to get out I think get out of
course being director Jordan kills
previous film where this lady eats some
Froot Loops the next comment is one of
my favorites one of the things I
mentioned in the other video is that we
hear the announcer of the baseball game
say that the score is tied 1111 Ryan
Smith adds the announcers mention in
Minnesota
who's Pro team is called the twins okay
how about the twins rose up from being
the worst team in baseball in 2016 to
make the playoffs the following year
just as the doppelgangers rose up okay
I'm kidding it's true though they did
improve by 26 wins in 2017 Adelaide is
also wearing a white shirt that
continuously gets more and more red with
blood indicating her true character
being revealed as the movie progresses
also not a thing you missed but this was
an interesting comment
remember the Simpsons episode where Bart
has an evil twin named Hugo Hugo is
raised in the dark and fed on raw fish
at the end they realized Hugo was the
real Bart I do remember that episode and
I think what they realized at the end
was that the Bart we know is actually
the evil twin and I believe that was a
treehouse of horror segments I've
actually been thinking about doing a
treehouse of horror things you missed
episode one of these days so let me know
if that's something you'd like to say I
think the creepy voice of red came from
her voice box being crushed when she was
attacked as a child he or she is talking
about Eddie being strangled by the
doppelganger in the Hall of Mirrors I
saw several comments bring this up and I
guess it could be possible but I don't
think that's the case based on my own
but she was strangled by a child so
probably not strong enough to do any
damage I think it has more to do with
the fact that the doppelgangers only
communicate through grunting so she
didn't really get much experience with
speech and maybe added to by the fact
that she hadn't breathed the error on
the surface for over 30 years Charles
knew Goss adds I took the Jaws shirt as
a hints that the terror comes from below
yes love it's next things the little
girl is wearing a greenish turquoise
jumper that says though which means
rabbit in Vietnamese it checks out
translating all my videos to Vietnamese
is finally paying off thanks David
there's also the duality in the Michael
Jackson references the Thriller shirt
represents the normal versus zombie
Michael the red Thriller outfit versus
the tethers red jumpsuits and Michael
sing
Rhinestone love versus the tethers
playing leatherwork thank you the one
thing I was not really getting the point
of was the gloves in us Shai Franklin
Stein also added that she thinks the
werewolf mask is a reference to MJ's
Thriller and that video surprise ending
could be something there some mistakes
were made
brace for criticism the exit signs were
read yeah I don't really know why I said
they were green I guess it was just
because they sometimes are green and I
remembered it wrong but red fits the
color scheme of the movie obviously a
lot better the mask was Chewbacca I saw
quite a few comments saying that and if
this is supposed to be Chewie that's a
really bad mask I'm gonna stick with
Wolf Man on that one which also goes
nicely with the thriller reference since
that video contains a werewolf movie the
parents weren't doing
rock-paper-scissors a random couple were
yeah absolutely right I guess I just
remembered it wrong when I got out of
the theater the first time also someone
else posted the tethered version of the
couple playing rock-paper-scissors were
only shooting scissors at the end the
next one talks about the Alexa like
virtual assistant in Josh's house
I feel like naming the Alexa gadget Oh
philia was clever oh figlio was driven
mad by the dualities in her life such as
whether or not Hamlet loves her or is
only using her and whether she is paired
as her family sees her or an object as
Hamlet sees her she also ends up killing
herself and you can't get much more
heavy-handed than that this is a great
point and I knew there had to be some
reason behind the virtual assistant
having a Shakespearean name but I wasn't
making the connection until I read your
comment Thank You Robin
911 who else saw the big chunga's
laughing so hard I'm crying emoji
laughing so hard I'm crying emoji
laughing so hard I'm crying emoji this
is more of a thing you might have missed
in my episode of things you missed when
I was talking about the rabbits I snuck
in a picture of big chunga's at 9
minutes and 11 seconds not only does
this contain the number 11 but 911 is
the date of the attacks on the Twin
Towers in New York City another twin
reference the towers themselves form the
number 11 and it was a coordinated
attack on America just as the
doppelgangers make a coordinated attack
on America in the movie when Twin Towers
were built they were the tallest
buildings in the world just as big
chunga's is the biggest rabbets the
world has ever known and if you don't
believe me then I don't think you can
fathom how big big chunga's actually is
Joker laughs also points out that they
mentioned the Twin Towers in
Hands Across America ad at the beginning
the freeze tube has some great comments
about the meaning behind the character
names Adelaide's name is like the
Australian city and Australia is known
as the land down under
Zhora means don in slavic languages
symbolizing the transition from night
today someone also added that her
doppelganger is called hombre which
means shadow should have known that
considering Umbreon is the dark type
evening
speaking of nintendo games there's one
more that i wanted to highlight and it's
actually something that i joked about
way back in december when i covered the
first trailer for us let's roll that
clip and when they're initially walking
to the beach there are long shadows
represent a dark version of themselves
since they have a dark version of
themselves they may also be the next
hits Nintendo franchise in fact if you
pause at 1 minute and 53 seconds into
the trailer you can clearly see Mario is
standing there holding hands with one of
the doppelgangers this one's called
scissors Mario while I was partially
joking at the time after seeing the
movie I wouldn't be surprised if the
inclusion of a character with a dark
doppelganger was intentional
Yuri Collard adds an excellent point
Super Mario is a character that goes
into tubes underground I love that idea
thanks to everybody who left a comment
apologies if I couldn't include yours if
I included all of them the video would
be like four days long click the
playlist on the left if you want to see
some things you missed on the trailers
for scary stories to tell in the dark
and remember to subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week bring
that DEATH BATTLE for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive